lady gaga has canceled the remaining ten  dates on her European tour due to quote  severe pain you're giving me a million  reasons to quit the show  give me in a statement posted to the  promoter site on Saturday Live Nation  revealed quote last night with strong  support from her medical team  Lady Gaga made the tough decision to  immediately come off the road mama  monster took to Twitter to apologize to  her fans saying she needed to put her  well-being first and plans to recover at  home all I know is that if I don't do  this I am NOT standing by the words or  meaning of my music the singer has  opened up about her struggles with  fibromyalgia in the past including on  her Netflix documentary 5 foot 2 I for 5  years and the fury in all of this is  that I'm strong and I can still be me  and when I feel the adrenaline of my  music and my fans like I can go but it  doesn't mean I'm not in pain